To be very frank with you vaynernation
I don't give a fuck if tyler or you think today was rough because I had 17 meetings that he couldn't be a part of
Because I'm actually running a fucking business here. I'm not from some fucking teenage beanie bopper trying to do a vlog or some fucking
Influencer doing a fucking blog or some fucking family that's open for some free detergent because of their fucking blog. I'm fucking
Working here Tyler. So sorry that your fucking video blog is rough
But let me tell you what's not rough? What's not rough is we're living through the great, era of
Ground shift in marketing and business everybody in this fucking amazing town of New York City
Which is let me just tell you everybody who's not here fucking vibrant at ten at p.m.
Right now cuz 98 percent of your cities are fucking sleeping
Everybody here is shitting their fucking collective pants because the ground is shifting
Everything that our grandparents and parents grew up with everything that we knew
Tried-And-true the stable
Pillars of Media Commerce
influence
Persuasion the way we make decisions the things we buy and how what is cool, and what is not is
unfuckin Call
The world is on call, and you know what that means hustlers the opportunity is obnoxious
so whether you're focusing on vlogs or
Influencers or how to have Instagram stories or how to create Alexa voice skills?
Or how to create your own podcast because you see I'm fucking full
committed tilt if you are not
following my podcast
fucking pissed
The way I call today the the sum up of all my meetings none of which you just watched is
That the Earth is moving
There's
Instabilities in the foundation of how it was which makes an innovator like me really fucking happy
And what suffocates all you "B" players because you like it you like it nice
Slow and stable let it be very clear with this ending rant
That game is over and the people that are gonna win over the next five to seven years are gonna be very comfortable in
Controlled fucking Chaos so you better get your speed up you better work harder
you better work smarter you better try things you better keep your
Subjectiveness and your ego at the door because that slows you down, and it doesn't make you do you better fucking move